lying Republican Congressman George
Santos has told so many lies
genuinely and I'm not saying this just
as kind of a phrase I mean genuinely
it's hard to keep up with all the lies
that he's told
well one of the lies he told was that
his mom died in 9 11. and we already
knew this was a lie or at least he was
lying about one of the claims he had
made about this topic because he said
his mom died 9 11. he said both of his
parents survived 9 11 and he said that
his mom in 2021 died five years in the
past which would not be 2001. so
something had to be off there
um and now we understand it has been
confirmed based on immigration records
that indeed he was like so let me remind
you about this first and then we'll take
a look at the new reporting here's him
saying both of his parents were down
there on 9 11 and survived and I can't
believe that that's the reality that
we're living in that I have to hear
somebody actually say that the 911
memorial canceled the same Memorial
where many New Yorkers long Islanders on
even New Jersey and Connecticut
residents perished
um First Responders uh law enforcement
everybody you know people working to
tell hours and media people everybody
just perished and and to to
I get emotional my parents were both
down there uh the day of the attacks and
fortunately none of them passed um but
to see that the families of those who
lost their loved ones will will be
recused from that okay
so you see that there and then
also which is a very contradictory he
said that
um his mother died on 9 11 as you'll see
a tweet up on the screen here 911
claimed my mother's life claimed my
mother's life but then in a different
tweet he said December 23rd and this is
in 2021 this year marks five years I
lost my best friend and Mentor mom you
will live forever in my heart so again I
say all those things can't be true
simultaneously both of his parents can't
survive 9 11. his mom died at 9 11 and
his mom died five years before 2021
really doesn't make sense and now I know
for sure that he was lying here from The
New York Times
representative George Santos of New York
has said consistently that his mother uh
Fatima devolder was working at her
office in the South Tower of the World
Trade Center during the September 11
2001 attacks even as he altered His
official biography to remove other false
claims Mr Santos account of ties to the
tragedy he remained but official
immigration documents reviewed by the
New York Times on Wednesday directly
contradict that claim too an application
for a visa to enter the United States
filed in 2003 Ms devolder said that she
had left the country for Brazil in June
1999 and had not returned since an
earlier paperwork filed in June 2001
three months before the attacks Mr
volder said that she had been unable to
return to the United States since 1999
because her Green Card had been stolen
in Brazil so now we have confirmation he
was definitely definitely lying
absolutely and each one of these
Revelations is stunning to me because I
just can't comprehend it and I was
explaining on my show kind of asking
myself the question for the audience why
do I keep talking about this we get it
he's a liar why is every single
Revelation have to be discussed and to
me it comes down to Fascination and
accountability
I am fascinated with a human person a
human being who lives in the same world
I live in
being able to be this dishonest this
deceitful this vile and his dishonesty
goes beyond just normal dishonesty that
we see in politics he picks the worst
things to be dishonest about pulling
from drawing from the trauma and the
devastation of people
saying that he lost employees in the
Pulse Nightclub shooting saying that he
had a Holocaust survivors in his family
saying that he had his mom either
survive or die in 9 11 and all of those
things weren't true that is so horrible
and so it's fascinating because I can't
understand it and it's wild and then
also if we are going to hold him
accountable or I should say if he's
going to be held accountable which it
doesn't look like he will be it's going
to be because this stays in the public
conversation and it's unfortunate
because it looks like the only chance
for accountability is going to come
either with his legal troubles or with
uh his if he tries to run for reelection
in two years the Republican party is
standing behind him and that tells you a
lot about the modern Republican party
but all in all just really wild stuff
make sure you're subscribed to the David
Pacman show the YouTube channel but then
also if you like what you're seeing here
as I'm guest hosting for David today
follow my YouTube channel subscribe to
it Luke Beasley on YouTube quick break
we'll be right back